Senator Ted Cruz of Texas is
leading a tour to the border.
This Friday and has written
a letter to President Biden
pleading with him to let
reporters come along and part
of the letter reads as such
your administration clearly
and emphatically refuse to offer
press access this is outrageous
and hypocritical and quote I
want to bring in now Senator
Cruz Republican from Texas
joining me now Senator welcome
to the program first of all,
you know the Lieutenant governor
Dan Patrick has told me the same
thing reporters not welcome
to come and that was weeks ago
what is going on what is it that
we can't see what what
don't they want us to know well
it's a crisis that's unfolding
it's getting worse and worse
every day it is the direct
result of political decisions
made by the Biden administration
as soon as Joe Biden was sworn
in he halted construction
on the border wall.
He reinstituted the failed
policy of catch and release.
So they're really releasing
illegal immigrants who are
detained now they're doing that
in many cases without COVID
testing them and he repealed
the Remain in Mexico policy,
which was a tremendous foreign
policy an immigration victory
that the Trump administration
had negotiated with Mexico Joe
Biden tore that apart
and the result is we're seeing
a crisis.
Last month over 100,000 illegal
aliens were detained
at the border and it's getting
worse we're seeing in particular
more and more kids unaccompanied
kids young children kids
in cages as the media told us
four four four years
relentlessly during Donald Trump
when there are a lot more kids
in cages right now and the Biden
administration doesn't want
anyone to know this.
And so on Friday I'm taking 17
senators down to the border
to meet with border patrol
to see the detention facilities
to visit with law enforcement
to hear the concerns down
on the border in Texas.
I've spent a lot of time down
there and astonishingly
the Biden administration is
refusing to allow any media
to accompany us we had requests
Fox News wanted to come with us
ABC News wanted to come with us
in bed with us and the Biden
administration's argument
it's really quite absurd is that
apparently the media you guys
are too much of a risk of COVID.
That's their stated
justification never mind that
they are packing thousands upon
thousands of illegal immigrants
in packed facilities it is
reporters and cameramen that
Pose the COVID COVID threat
and Harris that's obviously
absurd I can tell you I've taken
border trips I've been to those
facilities many times
in the Obama administration
in the Trump administration
and they've always let media
in it is only the Biden
administration that is engaged
in this blackout well look there
is another type of spread
and that is hypocrisy and a lack
of transparency and so that is
also what they don't want us
to see I would imagine a couple
of questions for you,
though because I really want
to understand the logistics
of this so our reporter just
said that 150 people at least
that we know about could be more
right have not had court date
set that's usually what happens
you come over the due process
starts and then they give you
a date you report
so on and so forth so that we
can keep up with people
we're doing a call us back.
Reach backload Yeah how much
of that is happening Well
it's catch and release which
they they've implemented
in place and you combine that
with ending the Remain in Mexico
policy so many the majority
of those crossing the border
illegally are not from Mexico
many of them are from Central
America and they travel
illegally through Mexico
and with the Trump
administration negotiated with
the government of Mexico is that
if they file an asylum
application in the United States
that they remain in Mexico while
that case is pending the Biden
administration decided they
didn't want to do that.
Instead,
they wanted to release them
they're releasing many of them
in my home state of Texas
and I'll tell you Harris
in Harlingen Texas the rate
of COVID positive cases among
the illegal immigrants that
they're releasing is more than
seven times greater than
the rate in the US population it
is indefensible and it is
a public health risk
and the Biden administration
it's why they don't want
the press to know about it
they're trying to cover up this
crisis and it's self created it
is Joe Biden that has created
this crisis so and I'm going
to ask my team to put up Vice
President Kamala Harris
because I do want to get
your response to this
just as she seemingly laughed
off a question from a reporter
who asked yesterday if she would
be visiting the border amid
the growing migrant crisis
here's the vice president you
to visit the border not today
but I have before and I'm sure I
will again we were left with
a very challenging situation
we've got to treat this issue
in a way that is reflective
of our values as Americans
and do it in a way that is fair
and is humane Senator Cruz
yesterday former President Trump
told me they were not left with
the situation that Democrats say
that they had a transition
and we can get into detail
at another time about that
but your
reaction well I got to say
watching that footage I served
with Kamala a number of years
in the Senate and to see her
just laugh at this crisis
at the border to see her laugh
at these children it is
a humanitarian crisis that
we've right now got thousands
upon thousands of little boys
and little girls being handed
over to human traffickers who
are physically abusing those
kids they're sexually abusing
those kids and the attitude
of Kamala and Joe Biden is
they're laughing at them.
That is not compassionate that
is not giving a damn I'll tell
you the Donna facility
the processing facility in Texas
it right now has nearly 4,000
illegal immigrants in that
facility it has a capacity
of 250 so it's it's 1,500 times
in excess of its capacity
and the reaction of the Biden
administration and Kamala Harris
is just to laugh and to keep
making it worse they still
won't fix it I actually
don't care if she laughs or not
what I care about is stop making
the problem worse stop releasing
people who are COVID positive
stop putting kids in harm's way
and stop releasing criminals
that prey on the community Well.
And if you factor
in the pandemic that are
in the health crisis that
we're in right now they have
created an international super
spreader event yet facilities
along our border
and they're terrified
they're terrified that
the people trying to get any
images of it that's exactly
right Yeah the gag order
I'm curious if Congress can
investigate that I'll bring it
back on another day I want
to dig deeper because I have
never seen this kind of power
exercised in this country
to keep us gagged and Fox News
is willing to speak about it
but the fact that every news
station is not outrage
if if Donald Trump had done this
and said no reporters are
allowed on the border the media
would have rightly lost
their minds and would have been
right to right now too many
of the reporters
in the mainstream media they
view their job as being
cheerleaders for the Biden
administration and apologizing
for it I think the media has
a right to be there
and I'm fighting for the media
to be able to go and see
what's happening and get
pictures and and see the crisis
that's happening to our jobs.
That's exactly right Senator Ted
Cruz of the great state
of Texas.
Thank you for your time
perspective and we'll follow
as much as we can as closely
as we can what you do
at the border thank you.